alors j'ose dire le problème que j'ai
avec cette histoire je vais expliquer
aux téléspectateurs
c'est que là ils veulent faire le bac en
contrôle continu donc c'est sur quoi il
a dit si sur les deux premiers
trimestres de l'année termine mais moi
je vous l'expliqué un truc c'est qu'il
ya des lycées où ils ont un tel niveau
c'est à dire qu'il ya un mec qui a le
meilleur de la classe il peut avoir 11
en maths parce que le niveau est
complètement fou et après tous les
élèves quand ils sont dans des lycées
très très fort ils peuvent avoir et
dévoile à nous des réponses à sa série
alors c'est quoi commencer
reconnaissez par rapport aux niveaux
très une présumée du lycée en question
adacore ont lissé les notes et aborder
les lycées c'est qui qui note très dur
parce que d'un très haut niveau à corps
ouvert leur montrent enfin voilà on va y
rajoute un point par exemple site à 9,1
c'est le point supérieur tu passes à dix
ah ouais je parle du bac je n'ai pas ce
qu'on voit là foot et ça c'est n'importe
quoi
sanader les mecs c'est à la tête du cléo
j'aime bien lui mais lui deux points
encore à tort à 10,2 temps à 11 mai
projetée pas se battre face aux
principaux geyrhalter non moi je pense
qu'il faut supprimer le bac
ben oui me dérange comme s est
complètement obsolète c'est un vieil
étalons kaki marché avant dans la mode
assis républicaine aujourd'hui sap
d'abord ça coûte super cher organisé
genre 2 milliards n'en a pas on n'a pas
d'argent a dépecé la joconde quoi
exactement
séoul a ajouté deux matches on supprime
le bac ensuite on gonfle
artificiellement les notes pour ceux qui
ont le bac
ceux qui veulent faire des études à
présent pas besoin de bach en fait on
est déjà inscrit dans l'est dans les
universités tout ça pour cent le bacon
nature n'a pas besoin en plus un bordel
pour les parents qui ont des enfants
dans les collèges parce qu'on peut pas
mettre ses enfants quand il ya les
épreuves et tout parce que les lycées ou
les collèges sont accaparés donc moi je
pense qu'il faut supprimer le bac et que
cela marche plus d'une fois cette année
cette année ou tous le sont tout le
temps en temps réel où se mêlent baky la
vie série oui je suis désolé parce que
géraldine tu fais partie et je te
reproche pas du tout d'une certaine
catégorie de foncer ou le bac je me
porte vers les études supérieures tout
le monde ne pas fait pas des niches
ailleurs il y en a sur les moyens y en a
pour qui c'est le seul segment guideront
de l'orbit d'après seront obligés de
travailler sur les familles il faut
travailler c'est au carry le rouet
tahoua l'argent sert qu'à la fin 81 2% à
81 86 pour savoir laquelle
alors je te plaît querrec 86 % des gens
qui n'ont pas le bac mais elle a quand
même 14 qui l'ont pas eh bien oui voilà
donc c'est quand même ça reste quand
même si pour son ministre qui depuis l'a
depuis le 21e siècle qui n'ont eu qui
n'ont que le bac et son ministre quand
même donc la même réussi à mener à bien
sûr qu'on peut réussir juste avec le bac